assurément le rapporteur public n'a pas
fait durer le suspense durant plus de
trente minutes il a contesté la légalité
de cette décision
un réquisitoire contre la mairie de
chalon la laïcité dit il n'inclut pas un
menu simple une démonstration
méticuleuse qui débouche sur un constat
pourquoi changer un fonctionnement qui a
fait ses preuves depuis 34 ans
stupéfaction du merrell r gilles platret
il importe que tous les enfants soient
traités avec égalité
nous n'avons pas à connaître leur
religion ils sont traités comme des
enfants de la république française ils
sont accueillis dans les écoles je note
d'ailleurs une chose c'est que depuis
trois ans maintenant il n'y a plus de
place finition dans les cantines de
chalon nous n'avons perdu aucun enfant
la fréquentation est restée la même et
le service fonctionne sans aucun
incident et la politique de prendre le
pas sur le judiciaire la ligue de
défense des musulmans évoque ces
communes frontiste qui emboîte le pas de
gilles platret c'est une affaire qui est
qui et politique parce que les les élus
de droite et d'extrême droite s'empare
de la laïcité pour en faire un arsenal
répressif anti musulman donc c'est eux
qui au fond de la laïcité de ce beau
principe de laïcité
un argument politique dans le rôle dans
leur logique de stigmatisation et de la
discrimination
impossible ce soir de mesurer l'impact
de cette audience c'est sur la base d'un
vide juridique que la justice va devoir
se prononcer la cour administrative
d'appel de lyon rendra sa décision le 23
octobre prochain
une décision qui pourrait impacter
lourdement le fonctionnement des
collectivités locales